p
bien bonjour nous allons voir
aujourd'hui est bien une ouverture très
importante puisque c'est la sicilienne
eux fermés jean baptiste
oui on s'attaque à cette défense
sicilienne en fait pas vraiment
sicilienne puisque la 6e fermé fait
partie de la famille des antilles
sicilienne mais on aura l'occasion
peut-être d'aborder les thèmes
stratégiques majeures de la cécilienne
est la raison pour laquelle les blancs
souhaite fermer la sicilienne et avec
des idées communes qui sont
caractéristiques qui diffère de des
grandes lignes siciliano ouverte
oui bien sûr ça diffère donc c'est un
choix des blancs de ne pas rentrer dans
les grandes lignes de cette ici nous
verte qui est quand même une arme de
contre attaque magnifique pour les noirs
oui et d'essayer d'étouffer un peu
l'adversaire voile alors l'idée
de la ccn ferme et effectivement ça ne
pas rentrer dans cette arme de contre
attaque que tu penses que c'est très
bien c'est une ouverture qui a été
beaucoup développée par par les joueurs
anglais dans les années 90 comme nigel
short ou michael adams
et qui a cependant le succès auprès des
joueurs de tournoi puisque c'est quand
même une arme assez intéressante et en
même temps il ya beaucoup moins de
théorie à connaître que sur les grandes
lignes de la suite de la défense
sicilienne
donc c'est une arme qui les intérêts
qu'il est vraiment intéressant de
connaître et qu'il faut connaître avec
les noirs si on veut jouer sicilienne
puisque on peut se heurter à cette
session c'est ce refus disons
d'ouverture mais qui n'en est pas moins
ce n'est pas un refus de combat au
contraire il faut savoir lutter contre
des grands joueurs l'ont employé on peut
notamment c'était l'espace khiasma série
de travaux spécialistes la dame ses
chances en or un joueur
voilà un espace qui chante en duo et en
plus donc on va voir ça tout de suite
alors si on peut voir notre échiquier
voilà donc la sicilienne
évidemment avec les compos 4 c 5 de la
part de adams et hollande
voilà si on a choisi une partie entre
adams y allant d'une partie vision
repères voilà donc on va développer dans
d'autres le sont que des stéphane l'idée
du coup du coup c'est simple puisque
l'aca n'apparaîtra pas vraiment dans le
dans cette partie là puisque les sûr
parce que les blancs ne vont pas ne pas
ouvrir donc on vous invite à découvrir
toutes les tous les thèmes sicilien dans
les prochaines élections sur la
cécilienne exactement donc là ici on
choisit la variante donc fermé qui se
débute en général du coup cavalli c3
coislin sur le cavalier de zelda mi6 en
c3 au lieu de sortir en général plutôt
l'autre cavaliers dans le ciel ouverte
et on va voir ce que à quoi ça mais non
alors que celui ci avait ouverte une
scène ouverte si on ouvre le centre on
pousse le coût des deux des quatre avec
le soutien du cavalier f3 voilà donc par
conséquent quand on ne prépare pas ce
coup d2 d4
c'est une sixième fermé donc on est dans
la ferme et cavale et ses 6 pour les
noirs alors voilà un coût qui est très
logique
stéphane puisque l'idée qui va guider
les noirs dans les premiers coups de
cette partie ça va être de se dire tiens
les blancs n'ont pas voulu jouer des
quatre n'ont pas voulu préparer le coût
des quatre est pas pris part prise de
contrôle des cases noires en fait avec
le cavaliere 3 donc on
les noirs sont dix lots c'est un moyen
pour moi de prendre contrôle voilà ils
ont pas ils ont pas voulu contrôler le
centre de manière plus importante comme
il aurait pu le faire
je ne veux pas d'en laisser la
possibilité de le faire plus tard voilà
je veux pas qu'ils diffèrent secoue donc
à wall-e celsis c'est le coup le plus
logique qu'ils soient dans ce type de
position bien sûr d'autres coûts sont
possibles mais qu'elle était si c'est de
loin le meilleur donc là à partir de là
on voit la sicilienne fermé classique
qui débute par le coup j'ai 3 voilà ici
ce coup là donc on veut sortir le fou en
fait j'ai deux enfants qu'eto'o est en
fait donc on n'ouvre pas le centre et on
va pas rendre en gros contrôle par
contre des cases blanches est un c'est
ça l'idée alors l'idée c'est que
forcément quand on contrôle un peu moins
le centre qu'on leur effet sur une
sixième ouverte et bien on sait que pour
sortir les pièces au centre il faut
quand même une assise au centre assez
importante
et comme on ne l'a pas eh bien on va
trouver
des voies différentes pour nos pièces et
là en l'occurrence pour le faut et fin
ce sera d'aller sur le fils keto et
d'occuper une donnée intéressante avec
le contrôle de la caisse des simples
comme tu l'as dit fort justement
donc on suit cette idée le coup suivant
des noirs est logique si on a compris ce
contrôle des quinze mois restent
incompris vite et la précédente on
comprend qu'il faut juger si c'est
mettre le four ancien ghetto également
pour pouvoir contrôler cette grande
diagonale
voilà que les cases noires et en
particulier la case des quatre avec le
pion lecavalier le fou maintenant on va
très très bien contrôler ces cas noir
donc c'est la contrepartie que les
blancs donnent au noir il compte autant
on les blancs vont avoir le contrôle et
cases blanches et les noirs les quins
noir donc fou j'ai deux classiques
voilà les deux camps les deux camps
occupent ou contrôles en tous cas une
couleur de castes différentes à distance
je dirais voit la fouge et de fouché
cède donc développement normal donc
maintenant des trois on comprend bien
que les blancs ne peuvent plus jouer
envisager de jouer des 4 on voit bien qu
on vienne le signaler comme c'est
extrêmement bien contrôlé au centre
j'insiste là dessus parce que
il faut que les noirs n'oublie jamais
que les blancs quand même on dans les
l'idée de jouer en ordre et des quatre
si les cils edwards leur permettent donc
il faut toujours contrôlé à fond cette
caste des quatre alors pas avec le pion
bien sûr un pas avec le pion parce que
si on met le pion aux cinq ça à faire le
décodage du fou et ça affaiblit la case
dessin qui est très très bien contrôlé
par les blancs donc on contrôle avec les
pièces avec les pièces donc des six pour
les noirs donc toujours dans l'idée de
contrôler aussi encore une fois les
cases noires on donne aussi un peu d'air
aux fous ces huit pour plus tard et
voilà on voit que les couloirs sont très
cohérent tout comme les coûts blanc
d'ailleurs chacun développe ses pièces
sur le talent fou droit donc le foulard
on me l'avait pas beaucoup de cas parce
qu'avec 4 il est toujours un peu mal à
l'aise puisque comme on a joué g3 il
peut pas à reculer ouais préfère jouer
un deux trois ou il est bien développé
puis commence à avoir un petit oeil sur
des quatre pieds sur des cadres alors il
faut aussi maintenant dévoilé le lit des
cachets de ccn fermé
sicilienne fermé c'est donc avec un
centre fermé quand le centre est fermé
ça nous autorise à attaquer sur les
aides sur les ailes
voilà donc on voit avec la disposition
de nos pions centre où des 3/4 que en
fait on est plutôt orienté vers l'est le
roi de l'échiquier cette orientation ici
comme ça on vous rappelle que justement
cette disposition de pions vous montre
toujours voilà c'est comme si sur
l'échiquier y avait une flèche ici on la
met dans vos parties
la forme des pions vous montre aussi où
jouer donc il faudra jouer sur les
droits pour attaquer sur les droits et
bien faudra attaquer le roi qui va faire
le petit rock et pour attaquer un rock
où il ya un fils keto on connaît bien la
disposition il faut mettre un fou en
trois une dame qui intervient en
batterie ni juste derrière on le verra
plus tard
et pourquoi pas plus tard allaient
s'échanger contre le fou du chien ghetto
à venir s'échanger ici - tard voilà une
batterie de komball portman qui est
assez classique alors l'idée pour les
noirs ici par contre très intéressante
c'est le coup tombé huit très malin
alors c'est c'est un coup je pense
qu'après le développement de la théorie
c'est une forme et on arrive à la
conclusion que ce coût est le meilleur
on peut même le jouer un coup plus tôt
avant des six d'ailleurs un peu jouer si
les possibilités je sais que c'est une
partie de leur peine
très vite le coutour bit parce qu'il
veut déstabiliser le cavalier c3
donc c'est un côté actif c'est-à-dire
qu'il prépare la poussée des 5 b 4 comme
à la foire et 5 évidemment le bcm pour
l'instant le cas à les contrôler et donc
je veux tourner 8 permet de tenir cette
poussée de deux pions et on acquiert le
pion et puis alors c'est un double
intérêt ses consignes à tous 1 8 de la
menace potentielle du fou j'ai 2 voilà
ça c'est un truc est très intéressant
c'est que le fou j'ai deux bad en a plus
c'est le tour en ligne de mire voilà mes
b5 b4 on voit la belle disposition des
purs noir 7 des six c'est 5 b 4 avec le
fou qui en jet set et évidemment on vise
aussi le pion b2 voila voila on vise
derrière ce pion ici
et potentiellement sous la menace du fg
set qui lui pour l'instant tape sur une
belle série de pièces le cavaly c3 le
cube et de la tour 1 donc c'est logique
pour le noir ils se pressent pas les
noirs pour l'instant de sortir ce
cavalier
voilà c'est le double avantage du coup
c'est que dans cette position qui est
fermé on attend un petit peu pour
développer les pièces on peut se le
permettre que je n'ai pas complètement
ouvert pourquoi parce que si on sort le
cavalier g8 stéphanie contrôlera plus le
pire en pire et 6 à 15 ans j'avais
beaucoup prochaine des blancs qui est
logique ces dames d2 voilà évidemment et
on voit bien que si le cavaly sort
maintenant évidemment fou h6 et on va
détruire ce fou qui est superbe c'est un
fou qui ressemble mais fou du dragon de
la sicilienne où là c'est clairement la
pièce la plus forte des noirs donc on
n'est pas contre l'échangé avec les
blancs ceci dit d'autres cavaliers
étrangers 8 on peut rien faire pour
l'instant tant que cavaliers je suis
vite si on protège bien la case d'où le
croquant de l'économie
d'où le coup doit maintenant logique
donc on touche pas aller loin pour
l'instant et on joue les cinq on veut
déstabiliser ce cavalier c3 voilà en
menaçant tout simplement le coût des
cadres c'est ce qui va se passer
d'ailleurs n'y a pas trop de
possibilités pour les blancs d'oeufs
d'éviter ça non non il faudrait pas le
retard d avec 1 3 ce serait d'ailleurs
en retard de même pas s'attarder réparé
puisque s'ils ont joué à trois on
pourrait éventuellement jouer à 5
voilà généralement quand on essaie
d'empêcher une poussée de pions bon à
moins vraiment qu'on bloque
définitivement mais à chaque fois qu'on
essaie de l'empêcher en fait on ne fait
que renforcer cette poussée dans le coup
pour se faire battre
voilà en fait quand la poussée va
vraiment se passer ça va être encore
plus fort ça va être encore plus
percutant donc il faut pas chercher
forcément à éviter les plans de l'autre
à cette folle donc logiquement ici les
blancs développent leurs cavaliers du
coup sûr la case honneur on peut dire
que jusqu'ici
jean-baptise cette position
l'idée générale mais cette position mais
mal et on peut dire qu'elle est
théorique c'est de la théorie oui ça
c'est une entrée de coups qu'on retrouve
très souvent dans la sicilienne alors on
a vu que lecavalier c6 et en mer mais ce
câble est en l'air mais en fait il n'y a
pas de vraie menace parce que si on joue
et 4,5 avec peut le faire là on peut
prendre du cavalier à tour des plus en
la tournée plus on a huit donc il ya un
problème pour les noirs tout de suite
alors cavaliers eux deux c'est un coût
qui est très malin en fait ça peut être
un coup de développement normal et c'est
un coût qui est plein de venant alors
qu'elle est quelle est l'idée de ce coup
il vient tout simplement si des noirs
s'endorment au coup suivant cd4 c'est le
coupe des 4 et voilà seigneur les blancs
ont déjà les cases blanches ils prennent
les quinze ans il ouvre le centre met ça
en fait ça justifierait pas les courbes
et 8 et b5 des noirs qui ont perdu du
temps qui n'ont pas développé les droits
donc le roi est encore au centre ce
serait extrêmement grave pour les pôles
et noirci le centre s'ouvrait et qui ont
affaibli la lorraine aussi oui d'accord
ils ont joué des coups de pions ce qu'on
ne conseille pas dans un début de partie
c'est ce que tu disais tout à l'heure
ses recettes emploi le rock fait tant
que parent donc attend que le centre est
fermé ça justifie en jeu sur l'aisne
voile avait dit que le centre soit je
ferai linge eux-mêmes plutôt lent tout
les tout est permis quand le quand le
centre est vraiment fermé mais encore
faudrait qu'il le soit et si après
cavalier e 2 il ya encore une
possibilité pour l'ouvrir c'est le coût
des quatre
donc ça veut dire qu'on est à voir à un
moment critique de l'ouverture voilà ça
quelque chose qu'il faut bien retenir
quand les blancs menace de jouer d3 d4
et il faut que les noirs l'en empêche
en jouant le coup suivant cavaliers des
quatre ans les coûts des cas depuis ce
qu'on bloque tout alors évidemment le
coup cavaliers prendre cavaliers des
cats seraient sanctionnés on va le
montrer tout de suite blender car à
l'époque à des quêtes des cas de
sanction puisque reprendre et du pion
évidemment le fou g7 protège le pion des
quatre et on voit qu'ici il y a une très
belle fourchette avec don kent une pièce
est donc ce serait la perte
une pièce net et probablement de la
partie assez rapidement et clairement
que
calais d'accord ne peut pas prendre du
cavalier on pourrait prendre du fou le 3
mai alors au 6 février de reprendre du
pillon oui et maintenant il ya plus de
problème sur la case à 6 on va pouvoir
développer voilà jusqu'à vallée est
obligé de repartir est vraiment à la
paire de fou disparition du fou de gaze
noire va être quand même préjudiciable
aux blancs puisque quand le centre va
s'ouvrir et bien le fou j'essaie doit
être très fort donc il appert de fou
pour les noirs dont l inde et de fouet
aux classes et les noirs que l'on a pris
aux intérêts à ouvrir la position bien
sûr alors évidemment donc il faut pas
prendre ce cavalier pour vous continuer
normalement donc localité quatre bombes
à des noirs ont bien joué d'accord il
faut continuer petit rock tranquillement
voilà pourquoi ne sont-ils cavaliers en
e2 aussi tout à l'heure c'est pour
pouvoir aller c'est le pion f libre une
poussée de pions qu'on joue quand même
assez souvent dans cette grotte là avec
4 4 4 pour envisager des f-5 plus tard
des choses comme ça c'est très clair
toujours les plans d'attaqué sur les
drones font donc la décade pour les
noirs donc ça y est c'est la
concrétisation du plan aussi de
déstabilisation du calice et 3 on voit
que les noirs avec cette chaîne de pions
contrôle parfaitement toutes les
diagonales en fait avec avec la chaîne
de pions et en plus c'est doublé par
l'action du foot j'ai cette ligne énorme
protéger une énorme pression sur toute
la boue de pression un total de pions et
de pièces contrôle total khalid ait un
donc là le coût est logique évidemment
alors à noter que lecavalier en des
récits altitoy sur la casse b2 qui est
toujours à l'attaqué par fuchs est très
important c'est pour ça que les blancs
ne doivent pas avoir trop peur de la
poussée b5 bekkat même si elle est bonne
puisque le cavalier en d1 il peut
protéger b2 alors
maintenant c'est une position un peu
resserré pour lui blanc peut-être que la
personne ne vous écoute va se dire ça
donne vraiment pas envie de jouer ça
avec les blancs puisque on se retrouve
maintenant quasiment toutes les pièces
sur la deuxième rangée sûr c'est pas
très réjouissant mais en fait
typiquement ce qu'on appelle une
position ressort c'est à dire que
cavaliers venus entre des cats pour pour
empêcher des quatre mais les quelques
pièces ont reculé et ensuite les pions
se libérer c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir
vous allez c'est à dire que là les
blancs pourraient menacer le coup c2 c3
plus tard peut-être on pourrait même
envisager le coup qu'à aller c'est un
pour éviter que le cavalier puissent
échanger
voilà une vie de ces trois et après des
quarts tu l'a très bien dit stéphane si
les noirs qui on va le voir vont faire
cavalier prend 2 qui est un bon coup si
les noirs jouent un coût de
développement par exemple eu six pour
jouer cavalier ou cette agilité au cices
pour jouer à l'idée de jouer cavalier ou
7 et nous garder la liberté du pion f
voilà et dans ce cas là les blancs pour
rejouer calice et voilà un pris un coup
hyper classique dans l'ancienne ferme et
on ne tolère pas
on n'autorise pas le cas validement à se
changer sur le cavalier ou deux on veut
s'en servir comme cibles pour avancer
nos pions avec un gain de temps donc on
veut jouer c'est pour alain cavalier
rouge après un échange peut-être et en
suis à lorient 2-2 lyon jouer des quatre
roues et aux banques des cas tout de
suite imité quatre décades tout de suite
et là les blancs ont obtenu l'opposition
qui est très confortable puisqu'il
possède deux centres très curieux les
deux carry comme ça j'ai presque envie
de dire on a l'impression d'une position
à la carpe au plein oui un petit peu oui
donc c'est bien pour les gens qui sont
fans de carproof il y en a beaucoup
jouer ce genre de position crois que
karpov et les spas et pas vraiment été
un adepte de cette non non non mais ça
lui aurait pas ça l'aurait pas gêné lui
d'avoir deux cavaliers sur la première
ça lui arrivait parfois bien sûr web
assez pour des facteurs positionnelle
pour gagner le centre donc après qu'à
valider un ont fait les noirs ne laisse
pas faire et joue tout simplement
voilà le coup de chèques accueille
l'épreuve de bien jouer puisque comme on
lit tout à l'heure la qualité 4 ne sera
plus une cible pour pour le plan c et
puis ça des vies également la dame de sa
case idéal je dirais avec la dame qui va
ensuite prendre en deux ans qu
obligatoire pour reprendre la pièce elle
ne contrôle plus la casse des 4l ne
contrôle plus en plus la classe datchy
ce contrôle plus le cas des 4l et plus
en liaison pour attaquer h6 donc c'est
le bon moment pour les noirs pour sentir
la carène voilà on peut sortir le
cavalier alors il ya deux façons de le
sortir tes fans on peut sortir soit un
f6 c'est tout à fait correct
d'ailleurs c'est là c'est le coup
d'autres parties de référence soit
essayer de
jouer en hausse est peut-être un peu
plus classique dans cette ouverture un
coup qu'on retrouvera assez souvent dans
d'autres variantes similaire de la ccn
fermé
l'idée de mettre le cavalier en recettes
pour pouvoir contrôler à la fois des
cinq mais aussi f5 f5 qui comme tu le
disais tout à l'heure et une case
importante puisque c'est là que les
blancs vont emmener leurs pirouettes
pour essayer d'ouvrir une ligne voilà
donc encore une fois ce qu'on vous
montre ici c'est une ligne principale
d'assister à une ferme et vous serez
peut-être vous avec les noirs confronter
à d'autres petites variantes de la ccn
fermé donc on vous donne en fait tout a
un tout un arsenal de manoeuvre que vous
pourrez utiliser comme bon vous semble
suivant les situations tout à fait donc
là je pense qu'on a donné les grandes
idées après on rentre dans une partie
qu'il faut jouer
voilà ça c'est ce sont les thèmes
principaux de la session fermée donc là
deux possibilités peut-être la plus
logique non ces cavaliers 6 voilà on
peut jeter un oeil au site
et après la partie continue donc sans
doute faire petit rock on va avec les
noirs continuer d'augmenter la pression
sur lui quasiment ici éventuellement
jouer à 5-4 alors il faut pas oublier
aussi que les noirs on peut être l'idée
de renforcer leur centre avec peut-être
donc d'abord petit rôle il faudra le
faire à mon dîner quand même bien sûr
voilà petit rock foulée cette fournée 7
pour contrôler être en face du fou j'ai
deux voilà et pourquoi pas eu 5 des cinq
est alors pourquoi je dis que 5 des cinq
ehpad est simple 5 alors que 5 des 5e 5
d'abord pour rendre au guichet ou 5
parce que sur des cinq comme dans les
céciliennes ouverte
il faut toujours regarder quand on joue
des 5-6 les blancs ne répondent pas plus
mais si les bleus répondent de 5 c'est
un problème vous oubliez secours mais
sûr parce que ça t'a créé le cavalier
qui serait même la pression et ça rend
terre le fouiller cet inter le fou gsm
alors on va voir une variante
possible encore au début qu'il faut
qu'il faut envisager d'entrer dans cette
ouverture doit pouvoir revenir parce
qu'on va revenir effectivement avec
d'autres systèmes fermés qui et je dirai
plus dangereuse si on connaît pas ça
peut aller très vite ça peut aller très
vite ça s'appelle avant le grand prix
attaque devant pékin sous variante un
ton très important on a vu la forme la
grande variantes des grandes idées c'est
mieux compris à peu près les principes
cette idée de tourbe et 8 noeuds par ok
trop tôt de bien contrôler la casamance
et a fait qui a fait fureur là encore il
ya dix quinze ans pas vraiment au top
niveau d'hier est un peu un peu en
dessous jusqu'à temps que la théorie
finalement trouve trouve des recettes
contre cette attaque grand prix ça veut
pas dire vous ne devez pas la jouer
encore une fois tout le monde n'est pas
forcément très bien préparé toutes les
ouvertures
c'est une variante attaque qui est tout
à fait intéressante ceci dit on sait que
les noirs dans des bonnes recettes pour
lutter contre ça et on va jeter un coup
d'oeil
donc c'est juste après cavalli c6 voilà
l'art et noir donc on est encore au tout
début
hélas les blancs peuvent choisir au lieu
de jouer le coup combien de voir le
coucher trois voilà ils vont il va
choisir éventuellement de développer
leur fou en c4 ils retardent un petit
peu ils vont jouer d'abord f4f 4 voilà
ça ça va plaire aux joueurs data sert
compte on fait mine de jouer une
sicilienne fermé mais en fait on rajoute
quelque chose de qu'il ya du venin voilà
qui est beaucoup plus agressif et on va
voir comment donc en général les noirs
répondre par le coup j'ai si oui cela
réside
l'idée stratégique n'a pas changé pour
les noirs contrôler la casse des quatre
donc fou ces cadres c'est la c4 c'est là
la grande différence puisqu'on a sorti
de france et quatre au lieu de le voir
jouer
j'ai trois rouges et 2 alors on avait
dit tout à l'heure oui mais le français
4 quand on possède pas entièrement
centre-ville x n'est pas forcément une
bonne idée parce qu'il n'est pas stable
eh bien oui c'est vrai et c'est
d'ailleurs grâce à cette idée là que les
noirs vont trouver une bonne suite pour
essayer de se défendre correctement il
faut faire attention
alors oui parce que tu vois ça vise le
pion le pion à vii ça peut aller très
vite un cavalier trois qualifiés sur la
menace évidemment c'est fou prend à vii
potentiels avaient des sacrifices qu'on
est dans le coup du berger
voilà visé par le faut donc cavalière 3
pour les pour les blancs tout de suite
il peut y avoir des idées de fou
princesse de cambridge et 5 voilà donc
il faut faire attention parce que très
vite aussi comme f5 suivi d'un petit
rock et c'est toute la colonne qui
s'ouvre c'est l'idée est née cette
variante
absolument donc c'est du potentiel ont
en général et noir prennent de la
disposition de tout de suite on est très
souvent d'ailleurs sur tous ces cas dans
la sicilienne oui même dans la sociale
ouverte ont joué le coup this way
lendemain on veut combler les cases
blanches à la volée round veut que le
fou c4 est un obstacle solide 70 bonal
avec l'idée aussi de préparer le coup
des cinq et on veut préparer le coup des
scènes qui tout de suite n'est pas
possible il ya quand même un deux trois
défenseurs pour les blancs et simplement
un seul pour les pour les noirs et enfin
de endémique le pion aux 6es la dame
18,3 contre 2 ça suffit pas donc petit
rôle pour les blancs wyeth de le rock
est arrivé très vite il a il peut y
avoir commencé à avoir des variantes à
base de f5 et en cas de prison m 5 avec
des possibilités de sacrifices henri vii
away il faut faire très attention et
donc les noirs doivent se dépêcher de
cerisiers pêchers invite pour contrôler
la case f5 pris la balle et la poussée
des seins voilà quand même je souhaite
avec la double idée un jeu contrôle f5
une fois de plus parce que l'idée que
c'est pour les lancers de jouer le coup
et quatre épisodes et aussi jeu à la
rose le coût des saignements glace et le
vrai le carrefour important pour les
noirs petite précision quand même sur le
coup eux six des noirs au cinquième coup
on peut peut-être revenir un tout petit
peu voilà on peut se dire quand même que
c'est problématique pour les cases
noires et par exemple un coup comme eux
4 5 vous pourrez regarder pour essayer
de préparer ensuite une manoeuvre de
cavaliers cavaliers ou quatre cavaliers
des six salles et aux 4 suivi de calais
décisif avec échelle peut-être embêtante
en fait ce n'est pas tant que ça mais il
faut réagir vite en revanche en mai des
six points de suite au jeu des c's faut
surtout pas ensuite il faut évidemment
contre-attaqué sur le point 5 il n'a pas
laissé
oui ce genre de manoeuvre tout à fait
voilà une précision de problèmes qu'il
fallait apporter puisque ça serait une
mauvaise surprise de voir arriver le
cavalier indécise très mauvaise surprise
effectivement elle a de la value 7 au 6e
coup ensuite
donc on revient la variante quand on
revient dans le principal donc sur petit
rock c'est détroit des trois noms contre
2,3 donc on joue pas encore le coup et
quatre scènes qu'il a pas vraiment de
sens dans cette c'est encore un peu
prématuré
c'est prématuré puisque l'on se pourrait
simplement le prendre avec lui pu bouger
oui et en cas de prise des vi nations et
les blancs ont des petites compensation
parce que 0 sans casser la structure de
pions parce que le roi noir même n'a pas
encore d'abri d'abris sûr on peut
prendre le pion c'est une possibilité
on peut aussi jouer des cinq ans veut
s'en tenir à notre plan si on veut pas
prendre trop de risques qui ne sauve pas
assurent n'est pas matérialiste et bien
on peut on peut jouer des cinq au lieu
de prendre le pur bien sûr voilà donc
des trois plus tranquille pour les
blancs plus sûr aussi et plus le plus
logique
il faut pas prendre trop de trop de la
en attendre à ce qu est la maintenance
et dessins voilà et la la c'est
finalement les noirs ont réussi à percer
au centre à imposer leur coup d'essai
qui est toujours un bon coup à jouer
quand on attaque en plus une pièce
adverse notamment le fou c4 c'est
toujours un coût très élevé à la journée
voilà pour continuer encore un peu le
renouveau va se retirer en b3 laon
warocqué petit rock à noter toujours que
maintenant la case m5 est toujours très
bien protégé par le clavier c'est le fou
ses collègues 400 ans voilà les deux
pions donc voyez comme on a empêché
toute velléité des blancs de mettre leur
plan à exécution sur tout autre
développement des noirs un peu je dirais
trop un peu trop optimistes et puis
qu'ils tiendraient pas compte de cette
menace cette poussée là pourrait devenir
il faut il faut savoir que même si on
contrôle plein de fois l5 les blancs
normalement devrait quand même le faire
quand même arriver à le faire pourquoi
pas ce qu'ils doivent libérer leur fou
c'est un pour attaquer sur wii parce que
tout l'idée de ces versets de dahlias
libéré sous et voilà d'ailleurs comment
est ce qu'on va faire pour échanger se
fout eh bien on va le savoir avec le
prochain coup des blancs qui écoute d'un
moment dames 1 voilà donc pouvoir
classique aussi dans la sicile et dans
votre choix en trouver ce coup de main
dans certaines variantes notamment les
quelques années y emmène dans la
discipline ouverte
oui bien sûr thème coup classique où on
va amener la dame sur la case h4 ou sur
la case d3 voilà les faits soit je crois
dans le ciel ouverte plutôt acheté
l'ancienne ferme la façon avisée h cette
ville se dépenser à 5 étoiles tracé pas
une question ouverte et de fermer si
c'est une robe noire à 15,5 et aux biens
fois les en h4 pour échanger le fou donc
damien est un bon choix d'attac
cavaliers des quatre cavaliers des
quatre avec l'idée est aussi de
supprimer trois compétences et commence
à se faire attaquer donc l'idée de
commencer à liquider des pièces
intéressantes puisque tratégie qu mans
on a bien réussi à l'ouverture on a le
centre donc il faut pas s'en mathémat
ans donc là les blancs ont intérêt à
prendre en d4 d'alors bill était un jeu
perd pas de temps et puis deux je libère
aussi l'action de matour sur la colonne
f pour pousser cette poussée f5 brin
tard donc c'est logique pour les blancs
de prendre les noirs prennent du plomb
s'est toujours pas perdre de temps pour
aussi mettre un pion est maintenant très
bien placés en d4 protégé par le fou g7
voilà un pion qui va cavaliers douar
bouger il faut bouger ce cavalier est là
alors là donc
il faut trouver quelque chose pour les
noirs on a un problème quand même c'est
que évident si on prend 1,4 on libère la
puissance du four b3 donc on n'a pas
très envie de le faire de l'autre côté
le fou s'est vite ici pour l'instant est
un peu un peu coincé donc il faut
trouver des idées alors voir peut-être
garder encore un coup noir parce que
c'est une idée qui est intéressante que
vous pouvez placer peut-être c'est le
coût à 5 à 5
alors bien sûr sa menace de prendre le
fou immédiatement le nascar 4 qui prend
le four b3 qui aura plus de 15
du coup les blancs doivent faire une
case donc ils jouent à 4 81 voix là et
ça c'est intéressant puisque maintenant
le fou n'est plus défendu que par un
pion et on a une petite idée
maintenant pour pour prendre en cible le
fourbe et 3d prend le 4 puis on prend un
cadre à l'action prend 2 4 comprend et
détroit qui est un très bon mental en d3
voilà donc on casse ici la seule le seul
pion qui tient sous foulée 3 et 6 e
foulées 3 n'est plus défendu eh bien on
s'aperçoit qu'il peut y avoir une
attaque double avec la dame en b6 qui
attaquerait le roi g1 et le four b3 par
exemple si on prend des trois ça marche
pas à cause d'un v6 échec
voilà et le four b3 serait en prison
clés noires ne peuvent même pas prendre
donc le karyu dix huit attaques et il
faut bouger
alors ouais donc laissé trois c'est
logique à la menance aperçoit ici que
les noirs en fait ont bien ouvert le jeu
pour pour leur pièce possède un jeu tout
à fait agréable position n'est pas perdu
pour les blancs ont encore beaucoup
peut-être car elle et ses 6 pour les
noirs là pour replacer les pièces
maintenant évidemment que on a ouvert on
veut on veut sans doute venir en d4
toujours pas possible de prendre en d3 à
cause de dame b 6 échecs qui prend le
fougueux 3 donc voilà une idée très
intéressante pour les noirs
effectivement dans cette cette ouverture
donc cette fameuse ouverture grand prix
ne pas laisser les rouler les blancs le
temps de monter leur pression aller loin
voilà on a bien réagi au centre comme
dirait rédactionnelle très important
toujours le centre ici donc le tel
projet race et dont le dira jamais assez
effectivement dit développement d'une
activité sur l action au centre
voilà un percement je bloque le centre
pour attaquer sur l'attaqué sur les gens
bloquent le centre donc les règles tout
à fait général je crois qu'on arrive au
bout de 7 de cette leçon mais malkin a
rapid en tout cas on a présenté pas mal
d'idées sur la ccn fermé scène était
intéressante à jouer pour les blancs
bien sûr c'est pas trop de temps pour
étudier toutes les lignes ouvertes
vous commencez par liliane fermé parce
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de thèmes
sicilien à l'intérieur c'est un bon
apprentissage pour la c6 vienne - vendre
une ouverte joué très longtemps l'avait
fermé ça me permettait peut-être de
reporter mes efforts d'apprentissage sur
d'autres d'ouverture bien sûr et une
ouverture est très intéressante et les
perspectives des têtes c'est pas à jouer
toute une vie parce que c'est un petit
peu lassant les thèmes sont les mêmes
tout le temps sur mais voilà pour en
faire un apprentissage de cécilienne
c'est une très bonne idée
le très beau donner quelques petites
ficelles pour les noirs et votre système
fermé
c'est un jeu qui va convenir aussi à un
joueur qui est qui qui n'aime pas trop
la tactique là c'est plus positionnelle
en haut mais lui c'est quand même une
notion de centre très forte voix
l'annoncé plutôt attachés aux notions
positionnelle mais le jour de la terre
on aura aussi pour son compte s'il le
veut on peut attaquer quand même assez
férocement - comme on l'a vu donc sur
l'aisne soul un libre accès l'idée on
ferme le centre pour une question est
elle si les noirs ne font pas ce qu'il
faut attaquer comme ça et les noirs
eux-mêmes
on l'a vu dans les grandes variantes
avec le coutour des huit baies 5 aussi
développent leurs activités sur l'est
donc c'est un jeune en a pour tous les
goûts
je dirais comme dans toutes lés
sicilienne qui est peut-être l'ouverture
la plus riche d
du jeu positionnelle très pointu il ya
des variantes attaques qui sont très
explosive
c'est clairement l'ouverture reconnue
comme la plus intéressante et bien merci
jean baptiste surprise stéphane gâteau
au revoir au revoir